hey guys it's Justine and I just wanted
to say I love you guys Happy New Year if
I haven't wished you one already welcome
to the new year to start this new year
off right I thought that I would do a
completely totally unique video no one
else is doing this you'll never see
another video like this one on the
Internet
especially today it is my first cell
phone I actually had been planning on
doing this video for a pretty long time
so I had to order all of the accessories
on eBay because the battery was
completely shot
you guys are gonna find this kind of
crazy but I basically refused to have a
phone because I hated talking on the
phone so much when I was younger and the
only thing that really got me into the
phone was when I was text messaging so
the phones that I had previous to this
one or my parents phones so my mom gave
me her hand-me-down raise her flip phone
that she had and then there was this
samsung phone that I had there was also
my parents and I was looking it up
trying to find it it was similar to this
but it was a gold color like this wasn't
pretty sure this was like the phone but
this is what it looked like
also it was folded I remember I had like
this little cord on it that I would
never drop it never drop it yeah okay
but this is the first one that I bought
with my very own money I went on my own
plan I hopped off the family plan this
is the palm tree oh I think it was like
the palm tree oh 7.50 if I recall so
this was released in January of 2007 it
says the internal memory is 128
megabytes samsung processor 240 by 240
touch display that was probably one of
the coolest things is being able to have
a touch display coming from these older
phones that I just didn't care like I
didn't like talking on the phone I
absolutely hated it but this had a
stylus and this stylus here I'll never
forget what I was watching the keynote
when Steve Jobs announced the original
iPhone and he was talking about who
needs a stylus yeah
Steve who does need a stylist absolutely
nobody so let's take a look at this
phone so you've got your headphone jack
you've got your charging ports here the
stylus and docking station and we've got
our camera which I thought was also
interesting here is it had like this
little mirror here so you would be able
to see yourself when you were taking a
picture this thing has absolutely mean
this has been through a lot of things
this was my baby
it was also crazy because I've been on
Twitter for an extremely long time and
it's interesting because back in the day
Twitter was basically made to just be
usable from text messages like you would
text Twitter like probably on here I
have a thread of me texting Twitter like
that's how you would tweet you didn't go
to the web there wasn't a Twitter app
you texted Twitter and the reason that
Twitter was originally 140 characters is
because the SMS limit back in the day
was 160 characters so they wanted to
give you enough space to be able to send
your tweet but also enough space for
your username so that's kind of the
reason behind the whole hundred forty
characters which is kind of interesting
because a lot of people don't even know
that so if you didn't know that leave a
comment below if you didn't know that I
guess also leave a comment below but I'm
about to boot this up I did manage to
get it working before but that was my
gosh I was probably like eight months
ago when I thought about doing this
video and I want to show you guys so the
battery goes pop this open I don't even
know where the battery is to be honest
with you but the one that was in here
didn't work so I just disposed of it
properly volume buttons here power
button and of course very nice
mmm crack here so my first videos - I
was kind of making fun of the stylus you
might remember this video and if you
don't remember it just disregard the
next few seconds
silence why do you have my it's so crazy
how fast time can just pass you by and
just looking at this phone and then
holding it up next to this iPhone it's
kind of overwhelming it's crazy to think
that this phone I probably got around
2007 like my entire existence my whole
life is so completely just different I
was still living in Pittsburgh or I had
just moved to San Francisco at that
point
holy moly it's turning on already okay
what is this saying to me what are you
saying my battery is almost empty well
but because I don't freaking have a
battery what the heck is that background
I'm swiped okay that doesn't clearly
doesn't work preferences brightness okay
is that better just go scroll through
these contacts here real quick this is
sir private scrolling time not for your
eyes these are all of my friends from
college like this is so cool I should go
through here and text every single
person from my phone and say hey do you
do you remember me okay I'm gonna show
you an email this is from Urban
Outfitters hope you're enjoying it so I
used to have a blog it was called tasty
blog snack calm so here's an email from
someone that says I'm on Twitter but no
one read it I use Google Talk let's see
what's in my downloads your phone's off
so I turn it on oh no what about the
camera
Wow look at this camera obviously
there's no front-facing should take a
picture are you ready
did I did this is crazy
149 K how am I gonna even get this to
myself a question okay here I'm zooming
in to X this little mirror thing is cool
Oh
oh my goodness I'll save it oh my gosh
I'm making a video
Hey hi so this is a video from my palm
tree oh let's have a flashback to 2007
let's go into the messaging Wow
hello a Happy New Year from 1231 2007
I've rested messages from people saying
to call me should I call them someone
asked me to go to breakfast it's now
time to look at some pictures and some
videos so here's the video that I just
made volume just have a speaker you work
so this is the last picture that I took
on this phone this looks like I think
I'm not sure where this is actually so
it looks like this is from North
Carolina my family used to go to North
Carolina all the time this looks like a
concert have no idea what this is but
it's the one it's a boy
this is oh my god so I was on the kill
point I was an extra so that's what
that's wrong San Francisco oh my gosh
crazy mocha snakes on a plane
this was oh my god this was in I think
that this was in Justin TVs place like
their first office there's a great shot
of me look at me look at me so dreamy
this was San Francisco
well good look good look why are we
doing I don't know what we're doing
french fries okay
alright the hottest dog this was it
looks like one of my first times in LA
there's this website called groover that
i used to you're just kind of like a
location-based social network oh there
we are that's my friend Karen oh my gosh
this is so wild reliving 2007 let me see
if there's anything that might be super
scandalous that you guys might be into
where do you see this scandalous shot
super scandalous a lot oh my gosh it's
Leo Laporte this was from San Francisco
I believe this was poor Macworld at
Bowie this actually was the time when
they announced the iPhone what is that
that's Starbucks yep tell that cranberry
bliss bar any day anything else
is scandalous I'm so not scandalous that
it's obnoxious it's me and Dez oh wow
this is so great I am really enjoying
making this video right now because it's
kind of cool just to sort of look back
just see things and remember because I
have a really bad memory which is one of
the reasons I actually started vlogging
in the first place was to just kind of
document the things that I've done and
my friends and mostly just to have a
good time and be able to look back on it
anyway all jokes aside this is such a
fun video and actually there are a bunch
of other youtubers that have been making
videos about their first phone so I'm
going to try to collect all of those and
put them all in the description below so
go say hi to all of the other people who
made this video and let me know in the
comments below what was your first phone
this was a really fun trip down memory
lane
I want to go through and just look at
some more of the photos and read some of
my old text messages I just kind of
relive that era in time because it's
really crazy that it was sort of before
of the first iPhone but it was kind of
like my first phone like this was my
first big-girl purchase and I moved to
San Francisco and that I lived in LA I
don't know what I was doing to be honest
with you like my parents told me that I
shouldn't leave and I should stay home
and I shouldn't move away but I didn't
listen and it was trying to talk to my
mom about it before I was like why did
she want it out what am I
like what did I say when I was moving
she's like you just said that you were
leaving and you left and I remember I
packed this hideous pink suitcase I had
a light that you may remember that
caught on fire several times in the
lightest video that I did I basically
move it across the country with one
suitcase my macbook that light and I
don't even know if I had a dream I
absolutely had no idea what I was doing
I moved here just because I had made one
trip here and I was like this is where
I'm gonna move and I did and I think
looking back at that it was probably one
of the biggest decisions of my life
because I didn't really have a job I was
still making YouTube videos but I had
basically no income like the money that
I was making was from design jobs a
little bit of kind of doing not really
sponsored stuff because it wasn't really
a thing back then I guess we're talking
like 2007 ish and it's really crazy just
to see how all of everything has changed
myself you guys a lot of you I've kind
of grown up with me so it's really cool
that a lot of you are still here so if
you are new hello welcome to the family
and if you've been here for a really
long time that's incredible and I love
you and thanks for just I don't know
being here and watching and supporting
because I do see you guys I read the
comments I read Twitter I'm always on
Instagram and I appreciate you so thank
you for appreciating and supporting me
and I will see you guys the next video
CES is coming up so look for some CES
videos coming soon if you're not already
subscribed to my channel please do so
and if you like this video hit like and
then
time I'm gonna go edit this video now so
I'll see you whenever I see you bye
[Music]